e arrivato il momento del pav i talk
show che il leccio di yotobi può
accompagnare sono molti di voi
dall'ultimo talk show
kat di talk show è che ho fatto mi
avevano chiesto che cosa perché a me
vengono gli sbalzi voce porca [ __ ] o
21 anni non è possibile capite perché
faccio i tagli porca eva lercia ma
sapete quante volte vi succede sta
merdata perché la voce quando ti cambia
quando cresci per fare questi sbalzi di
voce ogni tanto il problema è che ce le
ho date da sempre quindi cazzo smetti di
crescere corpo metti i muscoli non in
voce porca [ __ ] taggate a parte molti
di voi mi hanno chiesto dall ultimo talk
show di parlare un po del fatto di avere
dei fan che cosa comporta allora vi dico
la verità è un argomento che non ho mai
mai mai mai trattato sul canale ho solo
detto che sono timido e che quindi per
me non è così facile incontrare persone
che si mettono urlare quando mi vedono e
questo me lo avevo già detto ma facciamo
degli esempi pratici avere dei fan anche
se io mi definisco più amici che fanno
però atteggiamenti della maggior parte
di voi purtroppo sono da fan nel senso
che quando mi vedono in giro alcuni
grazia di dio solo alcuni si mettono a
urlare il nome valigie e porca [ __ ] il
problema di questa cosa che uno si
girano tutti quanti sia chi mi conosce
che che a sua volta mi chiede la foto
anche lui sia chi mi conosce non mi
segue ma sa chi sono si sa chi non mi
conosce si gira dicendo questo mo di
cazzo è uscito da uomini e donne tutti
quanti si girano che sia in treno che se
in piazza che sia da mia nonna si girano
tutti quanti e io rimango lì come
mongoloide a sorridere al tipo che mi ha
urlato fa vj e a fare così davanti a
tutti gli altri dicendo non guardatevi
che sono attivi però lo posso capire
perché molti di voi sono dei ragazzini e
i ragazzini quando vedo una persona che
seguono lo urlano il nome perché non
hanno abbastanza maturità da riuscire a
capire che magari se non urli e meglio
ma è normale allora vi espongo delle
situazioni tra i quali edile di partire
da quella top della vita che ogni tanto
la racconto perché fa troppo ridere che
mi sono successe quando un fan mi ha
riconosciuto partiamo dalla prima questa
è la top della vita ragazzi preparate mi
pare febbraio 2015 non vorrei sbagliarmi
non certo di ariana grande
aveva mandate concerto io e mia cugina
sapendo che la fanbase di ariana grande
molto simile alla mia ero preoccupato
nell'andar lì perché comunque quando è
un concerto soprattutto tipo ariana
grande justin bieber selena gomez mori è
pieno zeppo di file di gente di
ragazzini ho dovuto mettermi un
travestimento che avrà funzionato ma
ringrazio ero con una felpa abbastanza
grossa degli occhiali da sole un
berretto tipo di tipo quello di michael
jackson non trovo più il cappello di
michael jackson mi sono dovuto
arrangiare e mi coprivo così con la
maglietta per tentare di coprirmi il più
possibile e iniziava a far la fila per
entrare dentro il concetto ero in mezzo
ma proprio in mezzo a un orda di
ragazzine ma in mezzo propri tono che
ero nascosto così con gli occhiali da
solo il berretto e nessuno mi
riconosceva a un certo punto una ragazza
che sarà stata tipo dieci metri più
avanti di noi si gira il suo sguardo
cade sul mio preciso che culo continua a
guardarmi io la guardo entra me ne penso
niente di niente non dire niente no no
no dj [ __ ] [ __ ] rega è sceso anche
gesù in terra orcadi una [ __ ] non avete
idea di che cosa
la fila la fila tutta si è rivoltata
tutta la fila io sono diventato il
centro della fila c'è la gente si
rivolgeva verso di me e avevo 800 mila
persone da una parte 800.000 persone
dall'altra io ero in mezzo minchia è
stata una tragedia la tipa voi sì mi
ricordo che si è scusata la poverina non
pensava mai una roba del genere ma lo
posso capire solo che poi devo fare io
ho fatto le foto io già santini dopo il
fatto che comunque c'è sia il lato
positivo che il lato negativo di tutto
questo perché avere tanti fan che ti
riconoscono e bello cioè bellissimo
quando vado per strada c'è una persona
mi riconosce sono timido quindi
all'inizio mi prende male però poi
quando ci siamo salutati e tutto vado
via col sorriso perché sono contento che
una persona mi ha riconosciuto perché
sono persona mi riconosce e perché mi
segue e se una persona mi segue vuol
dire che sto facendo bene il mio lavoro
ed una cosa che a me piace tanto e sono
contento di questo è il lato negativo è
che diventa difficile fare le cose più
normali e questa è una cosa che io non
vi ho mai detto non l'ho mai detto a
nessuno in realtà alcuni lo sanno le
persone mi stanno più vicino lo sanno ed
è una cosa che io a voi non ho veramente
mai detto e adesso siamo entrati nei
argomento era di covare le cose più
normali è diventato molto molto
difficile perché se vai in centro non
puoi andarci normalmente se non ti bar
di tutto perché se si ferma una persona
poi se ne ferma un altro poi se ne ferma
un altro e poi facciamo un raduno quindi
io non posso andare mai quasi da nessuna
parte se non tipo in discoteca non posso
in
centro a milano posso ma il tipo il
sabato non posso da domenica non posso
perché pieno se per caso sto andando da
qualche parte che un appuntamento se
devo andare a comprarmi che cazzo ne so
dei vestiti diventa difficile perché in
realtà io non sto andando a comprare
city sta andando a far raduno e poi se
capita mica un proprio divistiche bello
ripeto però non vorrei che voi
fraintendesse la situazione però
purtroppo essendo una persona molto
chiusa caratterialmente ad esempio che
ne so secondo me ed ho da una faccia
recepito dalla casa sono venuto lui in
mezzo alla sala vi è meglio questa cosa
perché lui ha un carattere un po più
bella fra lui e molto più estroverso per
dire a mia molti mente toda non so che
dire anima per dire anche lui anche
sasha t1 messo la via è meglio perché
sono più estroversi di me io sono molto
timido caratterialmente e per me è un po
più difficile river mela normalmente
questa cosa perché non c'è niente di
normale in tutto questo non è che sono
mimì vedete quest'anno mi dovete fermare
tranquilli non demordo non è un problema
è solo e che video esposto il mio punto
di vista che alle volte non è proprio
tutto così meraviglioso come lo fanno
passare perché ci sono i lati negativi
vabbè stessa roba ecco la mia prima
volta che detto così sono malissimo la
prima volta che mi hanno riconosciuto in
tutta la mia vita quando mi hanno
riconosciuto brume fa vj è stato quando
ero ancora nel decidere di gaming nella
mia scuola nel mio istituto tecnico
quando andavo appunto ancora scuola un
ragazzo ha riconosciuto ai puffo che ai
tempi non avevo neanche la faccia nei
video non mettevamo la faccia l'aveva
riconosciuto dalla voce e poi ha chiesto
a dei puffi c'ero anch'io e io ero tutto
eccitato quando luca arrivato mi ha
detto guarda che ci hanno riconosciuto
il loro tipo dio veramente sono andata
da questo ragazzo che saluto si chiama
eros ciao eros che non è ramazzotti è un
altro euro e poi abbiamo parlato un po
del canale è stato superfigo la prima
volta che invece mi hanno riconosciuto
in massa e che quindi ho fatto un mini
mini mini raduno perché una persona mi
ha riconosciuto in pubblico è stato a
lucca del 2013 mi chiami ricordo tutto
cio l'alzheimer break per cosa ha
mangiato oggi a pranzo non mi ricordo
tutto il resto è un certo punto una fan
mi passa di fianco io non ero abituato a
questa roba quindi andavo in giro
tranquillamente così e mi ha
riconosciuto e quindi ha urlato anche
lei fa vj ma non l'ha solo urlato
purtroppo mi vede sta tipa da
lontanissimo tutti quanti si girano
su di me la tipa inizia a correre
velocissimo verso di me mi arriva
davanti e si inchina quale è stata una
delle mie prima volta che mi hanno
riconosciuto però non è stata bellissima
come volta ricordo proprio per questo si
è inchinata davanti a tutti e tutti i
granchi che guardavano lei che si
inchinava e io facevo alzati veloce che
sono riguarda non smetterò
se la vedo io ho questo tipo di
notorietà che non è neanche tanta non
oso immaginare tipo justin bieber con
che io vi ho descritto la parte più
divertente che era la parte brutta per
ora la parte più divertente la
descrivere che magari quando un giorno
finirà tutta questa questo riconoscermi
in giro molto probabilmente mi mancherà
questa cosa perché le cose belle vengono
a mancarti quando non ce l'hai più
perché finché ce le hai non te ne rendi
conto di quanto è bello quindi
sicuramente un giorno mi dirò minchiam
ora quanto ero [ __ ] a vivermela male
perché quanto vi darei per essere così
un giorno solo è probabilmente sarà così
però se vi avessi detto quanto è bello
quanto e divertente non avrebbe fatto
chiusi il video quindi vi ho detto la
parte brutta sono proprio un bravo
youtube kong ragazzi io concludo questo
episodio sui non so neanche come
intitolerò questo video tipo fan che mi
riconosco in giro e io sono un tipo
tutto timido non sarà proprio questo il
titolo prova concludo questo talk show
tirandovi fuori una curiosità che magari
prendono in un secondo talk show che
farò perché parlo di talk show che non
sa neanche chi cazzo è un talk show e
questa curiosità che ci sarebbe la
parlarne è che io so esattamente chi è
stato il mio primo iscritto lo so so che
non è una persona della mia famiglia non
è una persona amica dove no in realtà è
il faccio questa roba perché se vi
interessano i video dove parlo e basta
visto che ancora non ho capito
effettivamente se vi piacciono meno
almeno vi parlo di questa cosa di chi è
stato effettivamente al mio primo
iscritto a vela io concludo qui episodio
ragazzi siamo già dati su per oltre le
mie aspettative di bra che ho parlato
per mezz'ora di sta roba spero che vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi cosi se vi è
piaciuto solo un commento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e coniglio
prescrizione e noi ci rivediamo un
prossimo video della ragazza